[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo les temps forts de l'actualité à
l'assemblée et au sénat
notre invité cette semaine et la
sénatrice marie pierre de la gontrie et
c'est en train de nuit qui vous présente
bonjour bonjour bonjour marie pierre de
la gontrie vous êtes sénatrice
socialiste de paris vous avez été élu en
2010 est à la chambre haute et étiez en
quelque sorte prédestiné à la commission
des lois dont vous êtes aujourd'hui
vice-présidente avocate de profession
longtemps secrétaire national du ps aux
libertés publiques et à la justice
mais c'est sur un sujet de société qu'on
va vous entendre prochainement sur la
fin de vie vous portez une proposition
de loi pour légaliser l'aide active à
mourir c'est à dire l'euthanasie et le
suicide assisté est ce que pour vous
c'est vraiment le bon moment alors qu'on
a assez peu de recul sur la dernière loi
en la matière la loi classe leonetti
qaîda seulement de 2016 ça fait 40 ans
que un grand nombre de français milite
sur cette question parce que on meurt
mal en france et que c'est comme ça nous
allons tous mourir un jour
et donc nous savons que les soins
palliatifs sont une forme de réponse
nous savons que la législation a évolué
effectivement vous avez raison depuis
une quinzaine d'années mais qu'elle
n'est toujours pas satisfaisante
nous voyons bien au gré de l'actualité
des situations absolument terrible
malgré les directives anticipées malgré
la sédation profonde l'absolu mais quand
ça aurait eu à la dernière loi ce que ça
laisse nous ce que nous proposons c'est
que ce soit le patient qui souhaite au
coeur de la démarche est que ce ne
soient pas simplement dans les dernières
heures de la vie que le médecin ait la
possibilité de décider
c'est parfois très compliqué pour la
famille et puis nous l'avons vu encore
il ya quelques jours nous avons nous la
tristesse d'apprendre le décès d'une
camarade du parti socialiste qui a été
secrétaire d'état aux personnes âgées
paulette guinchard qui était malade
depuis un certain temps et qui a choisi
sa fin de vie en suisse et donc on est
obligé suicide assisté elle a choisi
suicide assisté
on est obligé de s'expatrier ce qui est
encore une autre violence
et donc nous voulons avancer dans cette
voie les français sont prêts puisque de
sondage en sondage c'est assez
stupéfiant d'ailleurs 90 % des français
sont d'accord et même je le précise
parce que certains pensent que ces sont
des questions religieuses
même chez les catholiques pratiquants
une majorité sont favorables donc oui il
est temps de le faire alors justement
marie pierre de la gontrie plusieurs
initiatives ont été lancées à
l'assemblée sur la fin dit qu'ils vont
dans le même sens que la vôtre est ce
que vous espérez un consensus trans
partisan sur sur ce sujet qui obligerait
à revoir le gouvernement à revoir le qui
obligera le gouvernement à revoir la loi
qui existe sur la fin de vie il est en
train de se passer quelque chose
c'est à dire qu'effectivement c'est une
question qui qui qui dépasse les
clivages partisans et nous avons
effectivement des initiatives
parlementaires assez conséquente puisque
donc la proposition de loi de mon groupe
vient jeudi prochain au sénat il y à une
autre proposition de loi qui va venir
mais cette fois à l'assemblée d'olivier
falorni qui est aujourd'hui au groupe
radical de gauche
le 8 avril et jean louis touraine qui
est député en marche a déposé un texte
casse 156 n'appelle à la loi peut bouger
ses longs cette évolution législative
peut avoir lieu alors que ce qui est
très intéressant c'est que on voit que
ces trans partisan ses transes assemblée
puisque assemblée sénat
pourquoi est ce que le gouvernement ne
ne s'en saisit pas pour moi c'est un peu
un mystère
parce que je l'aï dit tout à l'heure les
français sont très favorables et donc
nous avancions ensemble nous allons
prendre des initiatives ensemble nous
allons essayer comme nous l'avons fait
il ya quelques temps sur les violences
sexuelles sur mineurs ou c'est sur les
violences conjugales
nous allons essayer d'avancer ensemble
parce que les lésions l'attendent et la
place d'un calendrier parlementaire
avant la présidentielle de nouveau mais
attendez juste mans nous leur donnons
notre place c'est à dire que le texte
vient dans une niche parlementaire
olivier falorni c'est pareil niche
parlementaire c'est un ordre du jour
et au parlement donc justement c'est à
dire que là nous nous disons au
gouvernement puisque pour des raisons
que nous ignorons
vous ne semblez pas vouloir l'inscrire à
l'ordre de jour nous nous nous sommes
prêts c'est ce qui se passe sur les
violences sexuelles sur mineurs ou
finalement le garde des sceaux a décidé
de se raccrocher un véhicule is hâtif
qui est une proposition de loi alors on
a déroulé les titres tam
oui les sénateurs ont rendu leur copie
sur la très controversée proposition de
loi sur la sécurité globale
ils sont repartis de zéro pour réécrire
l'article 24 qui concentre les critiques
la lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique est au menu de l'assemblée le
débat législatif s'annonce riche mais
certains sujets du texte comme les
passoires thermiques ou encore le menu
végétarien divise
et puis on terminera cette émission avec
les auditions du gouvernement autour du
projet de loi comportant le respect des
principes de la république
eric dupond moretti le garde des sceaux
est apparu sur la défensive devant la
commission des lois
vous y étiez marie pierre de la gontrie
on va en parler et on va commencer avec
la proposition de loi sur la sécurité
globale revue et corrigée par les
sénateurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
souvenez-vous l'automne dernier
l'article 24 limitant la diffusion
d'image d'intervention de policiers de
gendarmes mettaient des français dans la
rue occasionnait une véritable crise
politique depuis le calme est revenu et
le sénat a largement remanié le texte
cécile 6 au bon call juridiquement la
proposition de loi sécurité globale a
été revu et corrigé par la commission
des lois qui a modifié en profondeur la
copie de l'assemblée nationale un texte
qui est à l'origine un peu faible dans
la sa robustesse juridique alors la
commission des lois du sénat a essayé
notamment en demandant à ma vie à la
cnil quand ils ont travaillé là
l'écriture juridique d'avoir quelque
chose de plus solide juridiquement parmi
les points retravailler un article qui a
fait couler beaucoup d'encre l'article
24 dont l'objectif était d'empêcher la
diffusion d'image de policiers de
gendarmes à des fins malveillantes
les sénateurs sont repartis de zéro ils
ont intégralement réécrit
nous avons dit depuis le départ que tel
qu'il était écrit il était
inconstitutionnel attentatoires aux
droits de l'homme et qu'il était une
évidente restriction de la liberté de la
presse la nouvelle version propose
d'introduire un délit de provocation à
l'identification
en d'autres termes désormais ce n'est
pas seulement la diffusion d'image qui
pourrait être sanctionné mais la
diffusion de toutes les données
concernant des forces de l'ordre à des
fins malveillantes autre article modifié
l'article 1 qui donne plus de pouvoir
aux polices municipales
une expérimentation pour les communes
volontaires que les sénateurs ont
allongé de trois à cinq ans pour en
étudier tous les effets ils ont surtout
réduit les pouvoirs judiciaires
initialement octroyé par l'assemblée à
cette police suis très réservé sur le
fait de déléguer ce qui est profondément
régalien sur la question de la sécurité
sur la question de 2,2 l'état ne peut ne
peut pas sous traiter et c'est un
problème majeur que de voir finalement
un démantèlement de l'état enfin les
sénateurs ont supprimé la possibilité de
rendre public l'enregistrement des
caméras piétons porté par les policiers
et les gendarmes
des images qui n'ont pas vocation selon
eux à alimenter le débat médiatique
le texte sera discuté en séance à partir
du 16 mars prochain marie pierre de la
gontrie beaucoup de choses dans ce texte
on va d'abord se concentrer sur
l'article 24 inca concentrer les les
polémiques il a été entièrement remaniée
par les rapporteurs du texte au sénat il
crée un délit de provocation à
l'identification des membres de forces
de l'ordre mais votre groupe ne va pas
le voter pourquoi c'est pas mieux
pourtant que l'assemblée nationale si
vous voulez bon on se souvient
effectivement du pataquès absolument
invraisemblable qui a été provoqué par
le texte initial mais pour tout dire bon
les rapporteurs ont tenté de d'améliorer
les choses
mais la formation oui mais la définition
est assez fumeuse pour tout dire
et puis un autre problème qu'il faut
évoquer c'est que nous allons débattre
dans quelques jours du texte sur les
principes de la république
sauf que dans cette dans ce texte il y a
également un article s'appellerait c'est
l'article 18 qui traite à peu près des
mêmes sujets mais qui rédigeait
différemment et dont le champ
d'application n'est pas le même quelle
conclusion faut-il en conclure voulait
bien c'est une bonne question moi j'ai
interrogé le ministre de l'intérieur
j'ai interrogé le garde des sceaux en
disant indépendamment de ce qu'on pense
du fonds comment est ce que vous faites
pour avoir deux textes qui cohabitent
dans le code pénal
l'élite rennes des mêmes choses à savoir
lequel a cliqué sénat l'été dans le cas
de fait n'a donc le miso l'intérieur a
dit non mais en fait ça n'a rien à voir
bon et quand ta garde des sceaux mais je
crois que nous en parlons tout à l'heure
il a lui aussi éludé
mais non ce qui est ce qui est très
curieux dans cette démarche c'est que on
voit bien que gérald darmanin aligne à
l'initiative du texte lorsque cet
amendement arrive sur l'article 24 veut
répondre aux policiers qui sont inquiets
de ce que l'on puisse identifier leurs
domiciles et ses terrasses qui est
effectivement c'est juste voulu par
contre quand même l'objectif de mieux
protéger les forces de l'ordre face à ce
type de problème protéger les forces de
l'ordre oui mais
ce qui est très étrange c'est qu'enfin
on est ici pour faire la loi
oui donc on ouvre son code pénal et on
regarde ce qui existe déjà
il existe beaucoup de choses et donc si
vous voulez le la rédaction d'un texte
déclaratif incantatoire dire aux
policiers ont fait quelque chose pour
vous des inserts mais il faut que ce
soit réelle et donc aujourd'hui nous
nous avons plusieurs points de vue
premièrement la question de la liberté
de l'information c'est réglé l'article
24 initiale a été supprimé deuxièmement
la rédaction proposée par le rapporteur
nous semble assez comment dire confuse
et du coup peut-être inapplicable
troisièmement il ya le texte principes
de la république séparatisme mais il va
falloir régler cette cette concurrence
d'articles et il faut arrêter de
raconter aux français que si on ne vote
pas ça les policiers ne seront pas
protégés alors sur cet article 24 qui
génère beaucoup de polémiques est ce que
vous pensez qu'un accord est possible
entre le sénat et l'assemblée sur une
rédaction comines
ou pas visiblement à l'assemblée choix
l'assemblée était quand même très très
embêté la simulation
donc j'imagine ils ont mal ce qu'elle a
rédigée penser qu'ils ont mal travaillé
le député animal députés de la majorité
et au sto l'art donc fait le texte est
venu
voilà ils n'ont pas osé le condamner le
réécrire ils l'ont défendue coûte que
coûte tout ça cafouille et beaucoup le
premier ministre a annoncé une
commission les sénateurs
c'est même ironique enregistrons cela
s'est compliqué bon donc je pense qu'il
ya une volonté de la part de la majorité
présidentielle d'avoir un texte qui soit
en tout cas juridiquement plus stable si
il est estimé que la rédaction proposée
par le rapporteur du sénat convient
voilà je pense enfin personnellement je
pense que le gouvernement aurait intérêt
à ce que tout ça effectivement ça pèse
et qu'une rédaction à peu près propre
soit élaborée mais je répète il y aura
le tec séparatisme donc de toute façon
il va bien falloir faire le fer le faire
le tri dans tout ça marie pierre de la
gontrie dans ce texte ya un article qui
est un peu passée sous les radars c'est
l'article 21 qui permet de rendre
publics les images de caméra piétons
pour permettre je cite l'information du
public sur les circonstances de
l'intervention
que faut-il craindre avec vous pour cet
article il ya des craintes pour le
travail journalistique à nouveau sur cet
article sur les noms mais en train de
publi reportage on c'est à dire que
autant les images on l'a tous vu protège
et chaque fois qu'il y a eu ce qu'on
peut appeler de manière un peu voilà
rapide mais résumé des bavures
policières ou des faits etc
ce sont toujours des images qui ont
permis de très bien donc c'est très
important
mais de là à considérer que ce sont les
images est établi par les policiers qui
doivent faire l'information ça me semble
qu'en quelque chose d'un petit peu
excessif donc oui encore une fois et
même je crois que loïc hervé qui
rapporteur du texte
cela dit dans des termes à peine plus
modéré que les miens bien sujet d'accord
là pour le coup entre la droite et la
gauche au sénat elle et on passe à
présent deuxième thème de cette émission
projet de loi climat et résilience le
texte qui entame son examen en
commission à l'assemblée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le texte est effectivement examiné en
commission spéciale les députés ont
auditionné les ministres avant la
discussion de ce projet de loi qui
s'annonce animé plus de 4500 amendements
à l'heure où l'on se bat à monter
déposés sur ce texte qui divise
explications d'elsa mandat gala pas
moins de cinq ministres auditionnés par
la commission spéciale chargée
d'examiner le projet de loi climat et
résilience
la ministre de la transition écologique
barbara pompili prévient le texte pourra
être modifiée mais pas à la baisse je
n'accepterai je tiens bien précisé je
n'accepterai c'est à dire que je
m'amuserai hamadi favorable que sur des
mesures qui conforte l'ambition de ce
texte et pas sur des mesures qui la
rabaisse après évidemment le parlement
est souvent et votera ce qu'ils veulent
parmi les mesures qui vont susciter le
débat la rénovation énergétique des
logements estampillés f et g
les fameuses passoires thermiques le
gouvernement est très attentif à l'idée
de ne pas braquer les propriétaires vous
pouvez pas dire aux citoyens français
aux propriétaires qui acheter son
logement qui est une passoire thermique
qui a parfois économisé toute sa vie
pour acheter ce logement
ben désolé vous avez 3 ans ou quatre ans
pour faire une rénovation énergétique
que total qui coûte je rappelle en
moyenne pour passer d'une passoire un
niveau adoubé mois logement de 90 m²
environ quarante à cinquante mille euros
c'est quarante à cinquante mille euros
personne ne les a avec cette loi il ne
sera plus possible de prendre l'avion
s'il ya une alternative en moins de 2h30
le gouvernement entend également lutter
contre l'artificialisation des sols en
limitant l'installation de grandes
surfaces commerciales
l'expérimentation d'une options
végétariennes quotidienne dans les
cantines scolaires ainsi que
l'interdiction des terrasses chauffées
autant de mesures qui promettent
d'intenses échanges entre la majorité et
les oppositions et au sein de la
majorité elle-même
marie pierre de la gontrie secours truc
c'est une bonne chose que des mesures
concrètes qui font entrer l'écologie
dans la vie quotidienne des français
soit mise à l'ordre du jour
du parlement sur le papier oui la
difficulté c'est que rappelez vous de
l'histoire de ceux de ce texte un
emmanuel macron décide après les gilet
jaune et cetera d'installer une
conférence citoyenne s'engage de manière
vibrante en expliquant que toutes les
propositions seront présentées sans
filtre alors les citoyens travaillent
font des propositions d'ailleurs j'étais
assez bluffé parce que ils ont passé un
nombre de week-end enfin tout ça a été
incroyable vous saluer çà quand même cet
exercice citoyen mais lady à la période
ce texte mais c'est la bise il sait très
bien le plus utilisé la société civile
le problème de ce genre d'exercice cfa
bon moi je je je me suis occupé de la
démocratie locale à paris quand bertrand
delanoë était lui donc j'ai eu
l'occasion a cependant ces années-là de
beaucoup pour réfléchir
le problème c'est que quand vous dites
ça vous avez intérêt à tenir ce que vous
racontez parce que les français sont pas
idiots c'est à dire que si on leur dit
voilà on vous consulte non c'est pas ce
qu'on fera un terrain là le président la
république pour des raisons que j'ignore
a dit à l'époque
ce sera présenté sans filtre au
parlement donc les personnes qui s'est
un peu des dix parce que entre la
technicienne entier pendant plus d'un an
pour travailler sur des sujets et puis
finalement 10h03 joker déjà on en
attendait il ya trois sujets en fait non
et puis au final bas regarder la
conférence citoyenne à noter l'ensemble
des chapitres qui n'a la moyenne ce rien
mais pas que il n'ya pas que la
conférence citoyenne parce que j'ai lu
quelque part que le gouvernement disait
oui mais certains membres de la
conférence citoyenne ont une vision
politique ce n'est pas forcément une
injure mais le haut conseil pour le
climat qui a été installé aussi par
emmanuel macron a lui aussi fait des
critiques très sévères
le conseil économique et social qui
n'est pas voilà donc tout le monde
trouve que ça ne va pas assez loin du
tout alors ça a été évoqué la sur la
question des passoires thermiques à la
question des transports
est ce qu'il ya un point dans ce texte
qui vous pose problème ou sur lequel
vous pensez qu'il faut avancer plus plus
plus plus vite plus fort je pense que
transports et logement sont les deux
sujets sur lequel il faut évidemment
mettre la barre plus haut donc
le problème il est là je vais
recommander à ccc difficile importer un
texte de ce genre vous une volonté
politique puissante mais là à les deux
textes sur le climat en sept dernières
années de quinquennat ya quand même une
volonté
oui mais ça oui mais ça c'est très bien
mais dans la vraie vie c'est quoi c'est
à dire que concrètement si c'est pour
raconter qu'on a fait quelque chose très
bien mais vous allez voir ce qui va se
passer c'est à dire que au final
personne n'est content quand je dis
personne n'est content c'est que soit
vous dites que vous voulez lutter pour
respecter les engagements qui ont été
pris l'accord de paris etc
vous proposez un certain nombre de
choses quitte d'ailleurs à vous faire
battre ensuite dans l'hémicycle mais
vous marquer une volonté politique
là ce qui a été proposé en décourager
javert en natif oui mais il faut voilà
tandis que là on est dans un entre deux
donc emmanuel macron ne pourra ni dire
je suis un écologiste vraiment
formidable parce que tout le monde lui
dira mais non parce que sur tel ou tel
point que des choses assez importante à
la vôtre ne rapporte pas je disais la
limitation des ou l'interdiction des
vols
lorsqu on peut se rendre à moins de
candidats train cinq lignes on sait
qu'ils n'y donc voilà donc c'est
toujours un petit peu c'est joliment
présentés mais en fait non voilà est ce
que vous pensez quand même que c'est le
bon moment aussi pour présenter cette
loi au parlement alors que les français
on demande finalement france est aussi
de faire de nouveaux efforts et
notamment à certains secteurs
économiques comme l'aérien alors même
que tout le monde s'est un petit peu
épuisé par la crise sanitaire c'est
quand même le bon moment alors je vais
vous dire si jamais le bon moment
oui en rien le ces gens mais voilà donc
pour toutes les réformes majeures s'est
jamais le bon moment
donc moi je préfère que ce soit ce genre
de chose qui soit porté aujourd'hui
plutôt que la réforme de
l'assurance-chômage moyenne c'est à dire
alors du jour non mais des efforts en
question sont demandés
les étudiants sont quand même assez
éloignée des efforts qui sont sur
plusieurs par ailleurs l'accord de paris
nous dit que si on respecte pas un
certain nombre de choses le la hausse du
niveau des températures et teradata
donc non je pense que en termes de bons
moments
je ne reprends pas à mon compte la
question vous posiez j'allais dire je ne
suis pas d'accord avec vous mais ce
n'était qu'une question dont vous aurez
une attitude constructive vis à vis de
ce texte vous allez élaborer des
conventions exigeante et c'est déjà le
cas à l'assemblée c'est à dire c'est que
poké cinq mille amendements
c'est quand même qu'il ya un problème
avec le texte enfin voilà enfin beaucoup
dans la majorité
et ben voilà donc voyons d'abord on agit
maintenant un accord dont les critiques
et on peut travailler quand on est dans
la majorité donc la démonstration est
faite quand il y en a beaucoup dans la
majorité on a une majorité qui est
modérément contrariante
encore une fois je conçois mais quand il
ya beaucoup d'amendements y compris de
sa propre majorité
c'est quelqu'un un petit sujet et le
débat ne fait que commencer sur ce
projet de loi climat on va terminer avec
le plus de la semaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous avons choisi de revenir cette
semaine sur les auditions autour du
projet de loi contre le séparatisme
le texte est pour l'essentiel porté par
gérald darmanin mais le garde des sceaux
eric dupond moretti est aussi venu
s'exprimer sur les articles qui le
concerne et certains échanges au sénat
ont tourné au vinaigre écoutez monsieur
le sénateur la pardonnez moi
bon vous pouvez jouer à cela c'est
facile moi je peux vous avoir sur
d'autres sujets
si nous inversions les rôles pourrait
vous poser un certain nombre de
questions sur des parties je ne sais pas
quand le vent est intéressant mais vous
êtes sénateur depuis longtemps pardon je
vous être sérieux là moi j'entends
répondre à toutes les questions je veux
prêterait volontiers à cet exercice qui
est parfaitement légitime mais vous
venez me chercher sur un texte
je n'y ai pas réfléchi je vous dit sur
le ton de la boutade amical que je suis
tout à fait disposé à ce que nous en
parlions si cela vous préoccupe
et je pense que si vous m'en parlez ce
qu'il y a derrière tout cela une
légitime préoccupation laquelle je
souhaite répond maintenant je n'ai pas
quatre ans je ne suis pas dans la cour
de récréation d'une école vous n'êtes
pas mon instituteur on va pas faire du
bourg bain quel est le prix du ticket de
métro ben ouais je préfère ne pas
répondre que de vous dire des âneries
mon mari pierre de la gontrie vous y
étiez c'est les sénateurs qui pose des
questions pièges c'est eric dupond
moretti qui maîtrise pas ses dossiers
ces taux dans cet échange à la 12e
j'ai eu un échange un peu du même acabit
lui non c'est assez troublant parce que
comment dire l'exercice en commission
consiste à débattre en plus
je ne sais pas comment ça se passait à
l'assemblée mais au sénat les choses se
font avec courtoisie vent moi ce qui me
frappe depuis le début c'est que eric
dupond moretti a un problème avec avec
les désaccords avec la confrontation
d'idées on le constate aussi en séance
et ça m'intrigue parce que et étant
avocat de formation comme vous voilà et
vous savez moi je raconte parfois que
première audience où j'étais un jour un
magistrat me dit m si vous ne supportez
pas la contradiction je vous suggère de
changer de métier autant vous dire que
j'étais jeune stagiaire
ça m'a bouleversé et voilà mais ce
n'était pas faux mais dont tu sais pas
curieux mais c'est à dire je vais la
retirer la robe d'avocat pour revêtir le
costume du mini c'est la contradiction
oui je ne le connais pas personnellement
mais je pense que c'est quelqu'un qui a
des difficultés avec la contradiction et
c'est dommage parce que là vraiment
enfin des questions qui lui étaient
posées que ce soit par philippe bas on
ne suis pas sûr que ce soit totalement
portant enfin voilà philippe bas et
quand même une personnalité importante
de l'état et du sénat il n'est pas de
mon groupe donc je n'ai aucun souci elle
reconnaître pourtant toutes les
questions sont légitimes dès lors
qu'elles sont imposées de manière
courtoise et les parlementaires étaient
dans leur rôle et ce matin total maul et
très vite
je vous dis moi j'ai alors c'est vrai
que moi de manière un peu rapide je
pensais que c'est très difficile quand
on est une femme en plus on se dira mais
bon peut-être que je n'ai pas dit les
choses comme il le fallait et état mais
en fait voilà donc quelque part ça m'a
presque consoler de voir que il était à
peu près aussi désagréable si bayonne
n'avait pas prévu non mais voilà donc il
ya une inadéquation entre le personnage
et la fonction et qui ne s'estompe pas
avec le temps et donc ça c'est un peu
dommage pour la qualité du travail une
question sur le fond de ce texte qui
arrive au sénat
dix projets de lois contre le
séparatisme si vous pensez que les
sénateurs aient l'air qui sont
majoritaires au sénat vont vont durcir
le texte
réécrire certaines parties notamment sur
le voile sur la radicalisation en prison
est-ce que ça va devenir un projet de
loi retailleau qui est patron des
sénateurs et l'air et qui veut se
présenter à la présidentielle ce n'est
pas une boutade mais posez lui la
question parce que non mais on n'a pas
encore commencé on a mené énormément
d'audition ne rapporta lecture politique
de cette évidemment c'est évidemment
possible nous verrons un an de l'attrait
je veux dire c'est que là c'est le
risque
écoutez nous on a quand même subi c'est
exactement le terme la la la
droitisation très nette du groupe et
l'air en un an sur la pma qui avait été
voté il ya un an et qui a été rejetée
ici vient du projet dont la devise est
servir texte bioéthique
donc on peut oui on peut l'imaginer et
je crois avoir lu que le président
retailleau avait bien l'intention
effectivement de porter un certain
nombre de propositions telles que celles
que vous évoquez donc on peut-être
est-ce que son groupe le suivra je ne
sais pas dans l'actualité est liée à ce
texte il ya ce sondage de l'ifop qui
montre que 52% des lycéens français sont
favorables au port de signes religieux
ostensibles dans les établissements 38%
vote une loi autorisant le port du
burkini
est-ce que ce sondage vous inquiète il
nous dit beaucoup de choses en tout cas
de ce que nous n'avons pas fait quand je
dis nous j'ai envie dire comme vous êtes
fort jeune ma génération c'est à dire
l'apprentissage de la laïcité
pourquoi est-ce que et c'est vrai que
moi je l'est déjà
rés c'est à dire qui est une commande il
ya une relation à la notion de laïcité
qui n'est pas la même dans les
générations plus jeunes pas forcément à
dos et comme jeunes adultes ne sera que
sur génisses sont elles qui se fait en
tout cas qui sont beaucoup plus dans ce
qu'on peut appeler la tolérance et c est
pourquoi est-ce que c'est préoccupant
c'est que ça veut donc dire que on a du
mal à faire comprendre le pourquoi il
faut absolument respecter cette laïcité
donc ça veut dire qu'on a un problème
dans nos explications dans notre
conviction donc ça appelle à lancer sans
ça la française et même critiqué à
l'étranger on a retenu entente est un
nombre de pays oui mais c'est à dire set
mais je pense que ça va déficit c'est
notre déficit que les cas l'islamophobe
est dépassé aussi parfois une critique
mais voilà donc c'est notre déficit
collectif de ne pas avoir su et de ne
pas savoir peut-être expliquer pourquoi
on ne renie pas le fait d'avoir des
convictions religieuses mais pourquoi il
nous semble que ça ne doit pas être fait
dans des l'état si constant merci le
marie pierre de la gontrie d'avoir été
l'invité de parlement hebdo
merci à mercier à toutes les deux et on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro 2 par le moyen de notre
invité sera le député socialiste de la
mayenne guillaume garot
[Musique]